thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show Cara is with us
from Boston hi Carl
how are you hi Dave I'm great thanks for
taking my call
sure what's up I'm kind of looking for
some motivation my husband and I and and
got debt-free except for the mortgage
and his friend did the opposite and
bought a very big house didn't pay off
his debts and now has a big mortgage but
the house is appreciated and he said to
me that basically he did what a head
which hedge funds do and so they've now
have according to him like seven hundred
and fifty thousand dollars in equity in
their house just from the market
appreciating and I'm kind of looking for
you're looking to see what your thoughts
are on that I'm wondering did my husband
I do the wrong thing should we bought
big house and sold it and made some
money that way instead of paying off
medical school loans you know what a
hedge fund is sort of not really it's an
ultra high-risk play for wealthy people
so the statement that he borrowed money
on his home up to his eyeballs in order
to make money on his home leveraged into
it is an ultra high-risk play that only
really rich people might do or be able
to survive if they did it so his
statement is absolutely ridiculous it's
moronic you wouldn't it wouldn't ever
yeah you wouldn't ever model personal
finance after a hedge fund and call that
intelligent that's moronic you follow me
because of the risk of him being
unemployed know that the hedge fund is
an ultra high-risk play they invest in
ultra high-risk things it's like playing
dice in Vegas okay in the investment
market that's what it's for and it
not something that the consumer would
ever invest in and so for him to compare
himself to hedge fund strategy is
moronic do you follow me I do it's kinda
like him saying okay me buying this
house is is like the world-class gambler
playing poker in Vegas okay that's kind
of dumb you know to compare yourself to
that number lon so is he winning yeah
you can win borrowing money in the short
term but borrowing money always
increases risk and the more money you
borrow the more risk you have would you
agree definitely and so he has taken on
a lot more risk than you have and when
the market turns or when life turns on
you not having any payments is a whole
different place to be than being
leveraged to your eyeballs people like
this guy go they shoot straight up and
when they crash they crash hard okay so
when he loses his income and he will
when there's something happens in his
life and something will because it does
in all of our lives we all have bumps in
the road then this is going to you know
it's going to reveal the stupidity of
his strategy the fact that he's
completely ignored risk in his strategy
okay you follow me last week and I felt
terrible if I clicked on the wrong thing
no no he's the idiot not you I mean
Warren Buffett says it this way you know
Warren Buffett is oh yeah okay
Warren Buffett does not believe in
leverage he says so in his annual report
and this way he says it is he says that
you can tell who was skinny-dipping when
the tide goes out that make sense
yeah that's a great metaphor a great
visual for you know the risk is exposed
the stupidity is exposed when hard times
hit so being debt free in good times
causes you to not have your cash tied up
meaning your monthly you don't have any
monthly payments so your most powerful
wealth building tool which is your
income can be used to build wealth in
good times in bad times what being
debt-free does
is it gives you the power to stay and
not lose everything okay
I'll give you another example right I
own a ton of real estate I own tens of
millions of dollars more real estate
than the guy we're discussing okay all
of its a hundred percent paid for the
building that I'm sitting in is worth
almost 20 million and it's paid for okay
just as an example all right now when
the market turned down you remember when
real estate went in the hole what three
years ago right for last longer than
that now what 2008 right right and
everybody was jumping off of buildings
in the world was coming to an end and
real estate people were going bankrupt
left and right all over the place all
these brilliant people that borrowed
money you know how much of my real
estate I lost you know how much money I
lost during that time zero zero
you know which money I made tens of
millions of dollars you know why because
I had cash laying around and I bought
more real estate while it was cheap I
bought a property for a million and a
half that I sold two weeks ago for four
million during that downturn all because
I was debt-free
okay now I'm not bragging on me
I'm saying the concept plays through in
good times and in bad times and I'm
giving you an example that makes your
friend look like small potatoes because
he is right I'm trying to encourage you
with this not brag I hope you hear the
difference yeah so you're going you know
here's the thing those guys can there
it always looks fun and sexy in the
short term when you ignore risk but but
when you ignore risk and you get old you
have scars so you guys are right on
track carry on your car oh you're doing
the right stuff and I feel sorry for
this guy because he's his risk meters
broken and you're going as his friend
you're gonna have to stand back and
watch him hit the wall when he hits the
wall it's gonna destroy everything and
he's gonna hurt you can be there and
pray with him and hurt with him when
they pick up the pieces and hopefully
you'll learn his lesson but I've been
around guys like that my whole life as a
matter of fact
was that guy that's how I went broke in
my 20s and that's how I learned all of
this the hard way how was that gone
steroids I mean I had four million
dollars for the real estate and I had
three million dollars worth of debt and
I was convinced that I was a millionaire
because I'd borrowed my way into it and
you know what I was a millionaire
because I'd borrowed my way into it
I was exactly right but I'd also built a
house of cards and so soon as the
banking climate changed and the economy
changed it brought me to my knees we
lost everything because of leverage and
because of the debt well Dave you're
just scarred yep what that means is I
learned my lesson I'm not stupid I don't
have to learn it over and over again I
learned it the first time it was painful
enough it was a thorough teacher great
discussion thank you for calling me with
that hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]